Hey guys, House of the Dragon is a Game of
Thrones prequel show that will air in 2022
on HBO.
It’s based on George RR Martin’s book
Fire And Blood.
The key event of the prequel will be the Dance
of the Dragon, a Targaryen civil war.
Although it's a Targaryen civil war, Targaryens
are not the only main characters in this time
period, one major character among them being
Corlys of House Velaryon, known as the Sea
Snake.
House Velaryon in general plays a key role
in this war.
The Dance of the Dragons was the most devastating
war in the history of the Seven Kingdoms.
A war of succession between Aegon II and his
half-sister Rhaenyra over their father Viserys
I's throne.
Both of them thought they belonged on the
Iron Throne.
When people started declaring for one of them
or the other, their fight divided the kingdoms
in two.
As I already said, the Game of Thrones prequel
series, House of the Dragon, although based
on George RR Martin's Targaryen history book
Fire & Blood, will not feature Targaryens
only, but many other houses and many other
legendary figures from that time period as
well, including the Velaryons had for centuries
remained the oldest and closest allies of
the Targaryens.
House Velaryon of Driftmark rules the island
of Driftmark, the largest island of Blackwater
Bay in the crownlands.
Their castle includes Driftmark and High Tide.
The head of House Velaryon is titled Lord
of the Tides and Master of Driftmark.
The Velaryons are sworn to Dragonstone.
Their arms depict a silver seahorse on sea
green.
Their words do not appear in the books, but
according to semi-canon sources they are "The
Old, the True, the Brave".
House Velaryon, much like House Targaryen,
is of Valyrian descent, and its members often
have Valyrian features, such as silver hair
and purple eyes.
The traditional name of the Velaryons is Jacaerys,
and in House of the Dragon, the main character
Rhaenyra’s oldest son is named Jacaerys,
as his father is from House Velaryon.
It’s traditional for the sons of House Velaryon
to be given a taste of a seafarer's life when
young.
The positions of master of ships and lord
admiral are often filled by a member of House
Velaryon, as the family provides most of the
royal fleet.
House Velaryon is an ancient and proud house,
with the blood of old Valyria in its veins.
A noble house with a storied Valyrian lineage,
the Velaryons had come to Westeros even before
the Targaryens, settling in the Gullet on
the low-lying and fertile isle of island of
Driftmark (so named for the driftwood that
the tides brought daily to its shores) rather
than its stony, smoking neighbor, Dragonstone.
The castle of Driftmark housed their ancient
high seat, the Driftwood Throne, which according
to legend had been given to them by the Merling
King to conclude a pact.
Although never dragonriders, the Velaryons
had for centuries remained the oldest and
closest allies of the Targaryens.
The sea was their element, not the sky.
During the Conquest, it was Velaryon ships
that carried Aegon’s soldiers across Blackwater
Bay, and later formed the greater part of
the royal fleet.
Throughout the first century of the Targaryen
rule, so many Lords of the Tides served on
the small council as master of ships that
the office was widely seen as almost hereditary.
They allied with House Targaryen from Dragonstone
and House Celtigar from Claw Isle, both houses
of Valyrian descent; while the Velaryons and
Celtigars dominated the middle reaches of
the narrow sea with their ships, the Targaryens
ruled the skies with their dragons.
The close relations between Houses Velaryon
and Targaryen resulted in multiple marriages
between the houses, both before and after
the Wars of Conquest.
Even the mother of Aegon the Conqueror was
a Velaryon.
House Velaryon officially allied with the
Targaryens at the start of Aegon's Conquest.
Lord Daemon Velaryon was made master of ships
by Aegon the Conqueror after the mouth of
the Blackwater Rush had been secured.
Daemon died fighting for Aegon I in the battle
in the waters off Gulltown, however.
House Velaryon kept an influential position
at the court of the Targaryen kings during
the first two centuries of the Targaryen reign.
It even was a Velaryon who became the first
Lord Commander of the Kingsguard for Aegon
the Conqueror.
The most famous and strongest Velaryion to
ever live is also one of the main characters
in the upcoming House of the Dragon show – Corlys
Velaryon, known as the Sea Snake.
He's a fabled Lord of the Tides during the
Targaryen civil war, Master of Driftmark,
and head of House Velaryon.
He is the husband of Princess Rhaenys Targaryen,
the Queen-Who-Never-Was.
During the Dance of the Dragons, he became
Hand to Queen Rhaenyra Targaryen who was his
niece and daughter-in-law.
By the of age seven-and-thirty, Corlys was
hailed as the greatest seafarer the Seven
Kingdoms had ever known.
Corlys was born in 53 AC to the eldest son
of Lord Daemon Velaryon.
He was named after his great-great uncle,
Ser Corlys Velaryon, who served King Aegonthe
Conqueror as the first Lord Commander of the
Kingsguard.
Ser Corlys sailed aboard his Sea Snake, a
ship he designed and built, on nine great
voyages to Essos.
During his final voyage on Sea Snake, Corlys
filled the ship's hold with gold and bought
twenty more ships at Qarth, loading them with
spices, elephants, and silk.
Only fourteen ships made it to Driftmark and
all the elephants died, but it was still more
than enough to make Corlys become the wealthiest
man in all of Westeros.
He took his nickname "Sea Snake" from his
famous ship.
SerCorlys became head of House Velaryon and
Lord of the Tides after the death of his grandsire.
Richer than Lords Lannister or Hightower through
his expeditions, Lord Corlys used his great
wealth to construct a new seat, High Tide,
where he stored his eastern treasures.
In 90 AC, Corlys married the sixteen-year
old Princess Rhaenys Targaryen, the only child
of Prince Aemon Targaryen, who in turn was
the eldest son of King Jaehaerys I Targaryen.
Two years later, Corlys sailed his fleet to
Tarth, to aid Prince Aemon in fighting the
Myrish exiles who had invaded the island.
Shortly before they left, Corlys's wife announced
she was pregnant.
During the campaign, Prince Aemon died, leading
King Jaehaerys I Targaryen to appoint a new
heir to the throne.
He chose his second son Baelon over Aemon's
only heir, Rhaenys, thereby also passing over
Corlys and Rhaenys's unborn child.
Furious over this decision, Corlys gave up
his admiralty and his place on the king's
small council and returned to Driftmark with
his wife.
In late 92 AC,Rhaenys gave birth to a daughter,
Laena.
A son, Laenor, followed in 94 AC.
When Prince Baelon died in 101 AC, King Jaehaerys
I's succession became unclear again, and reports
reached the court that Corlys was gathering
ships and men to defend the rights of his
son.
When the king declared a Great Council would
be held at Harrenhal to settle the succession,
Corlys and his wife traveled there, using
their wealth and influence to try and persuade
the lords present to vote for Laenor, after
Rhaenys and Laena had been passed over once
again on account of their gender.
Corlys's wealth, reputation and fame did much
to support Laenor's claim, but in the end,
Baelon's son Viserys received majority of
the votes, and was named the Prince of Dragonstone.
Following the death of Queen Aemma Arryn,
in 105 AC, Grand Maester Runciter suggested
to King Viserys I Targaryen that he shall
take Corlys's twelve-year-old daughter, Laena,
to wife.
King Viserys, however, chose Alicent Hightower.
Angered by the third time his wife and children
had been scorned by House Targaryen, Corlys
and his family did not attend the wedding
in 106 AC.
Instead, he made an alliance with Prince Daemon
Targaryen, King Viserys's younger brother,
equally angered by the King's marriage.
Lord Corlys and his fleet fought alongside
Prince Daemon Targaryen during the War for
the Stepstones.
When Daemon declared himself the King of the
Stepstones and the Narrow Sea, Corlys placed
the crown on the new king's head.
In 113 AC, King Viserys I and his small council
began discussions concerning a betrothal for
Princess Rhaenyra Targaryen, Viserys's heir.
They eventually agreed on Corlys's son, Laenor.
Laenor and Rhaenyra were married in 114 AC
and gave him 3 grandsons.
By 115 AC, Corlys saw his daughter Laena wed
to Daemon with his blessing.
Through this marriage, Corlys would have two
more grandchildren: the twins Baela and Rhaena
Targaryen, born in 116 AC.
The children of Corlys and Princess Rhaenys
Targaryen both died in 120 AC, Laena Velaryon
from childbed fever and Ser Laenor Velaryon
from a quarrel with a knight which is rumored
to have been organized by Daemon.
Later in the same year Prince Daemon, Laena's
widower, married Princess Rhaenyra Targaryen,
Laenor's widow.
When King Viserys I Targaryen died in early
129 AC, and the King's eldest son Aegon II
Targaryen ascended the throne, passing over
Viserys's appointed heir Rhaenyra, Corlys
traveled to Dragonstone to lend his support
in the struggle to his former daughter-in-law.
Lord Corlys Velaryon sat on the black council
during the civil war known as the Dance of
the Dragons; he was the greatest lord to pledge
his strength to the cause of Queen Rhaenyra
Targaryen, who was opposed by her half-brother,
King Aegon II Targaryen.
More than half of Rhaenyra's army was made
of men sworn to House Velaryon.
Corlys's fleet also gave the blacks superiority
at sea.
Corlys was Rhaenyra's Hand of the Queen.
When Lord Bartimos advised the princess to
fly from Dragonstone to King’s Landing at
once and reduce the city to ash and bone with
her dragon, Corlys demanded to know how that
would serve them, telling him "we want to
rule the city, not burn it to the ground".
You will see many Velaryons in the House of
the Dragon, with the Sea Snake having the
most screen time, of course.
He had served four kings and a queen, sailed
to the ends of the earth, raised House Velaryon
to unprecedented levels of wealth and power,
married a princess who might have been a queen,
fathered dragon riders, built towns and fleets,
proved his valor in times of war and his wisdom
in times of peace.
The Sea Snake’s life is so interesting that
there is another Game of Thrones prequel in
development, based on his life alone, called
9 Voyages.
Whether you like the Sea Snake and House Velaryon
or you prefer House Targaryen and their dragons,
all of that and more you’ll see in the House
of the Dragon in 2022 on HBO.
Thank you so much for watching and stay tuned.